à fin des années 30 les montréalais sont
étouffés par les tarifs d'électricité
trop élevés exigés par les producteurs
privés
le premier ministre libéral adélard
godbout nationalise donc en 1944 une
première entreprise la montreal light
weight and power mais le reste du québec
demeure sous l'emprise du trust de
l'électricité et l'influencé de la
nouvelle société d'état est limité à
montréal
début des années 60 un jeune ministre
libéral du nom de rené lévesque reçoit
la mission de convaincre le peuple de la
nécessité de nationaliser tout
l'électricité du québec c'est au peuple
du québec de prendre dans ses mains
librement et fièrement la première et la
plus importante de toutes les clés d'une
économie moderne ça ça veut dire la
nationalisation de l'électricité
c'est l'enjeu de l'élection de 1962 et
la victoire parti libéral marque le
véritable point de départ d'hydro-québec
la nationalisation d'électricité est une
grande et fructueuse à pair hydro québec
devient un puissant levier économique
pour certains historiens la création
diderot marque la fin d'une époque celle
du colonialisme économique dont est
victime le québec avec la baie james
c'est tout le génie québécois qui est à
l'oeuvre des barrages qui encore
aujourd'hui sont parmi les plus
imposantes la planète long du grand nord
devient l'or bleu du québec développer
l'hydroélectricité cc conquérir le nord
du québec le québec réussit en à peine
15 ans en moins d'une génération à se
libérer en très grande partie de sa
dépendance au pétrole
bien sûr les voitures roulent toujours à
l'essence mais dans les maisons des
québécois abandonne le chauffage au
mazout pour faire place à l'électricité
et la puissance diderot est largement
suffisante pour répondre aux besoins de
la grande industrie
mais cette conquête du grand nord sera
toutefois freiné pendant un certain
temps par les nations autochtones avec
le soutien d'environnementalistes
étrangers 1998 le verglas prises le
réseau jamais hydro québec n'a paru
aussi vulnérable au tournant des années
2000 jean charest remets hydro-québec au
coeur du développement économique
on développe l'éolien sans oublier
l'exploitation de la rivière romaine et
hydro refile la facture aux québécois en
augmentant les tarifs
cependant plus que normal à son salaire
sur scène aujourd'hui
hydro québec doit gérer d'énormes
surplus l'ontario n'en veut pas du côté
américain il faut une nouvelle ligne de
transport mais il y à de l'opposition
sinon d'où viendra la prospérité future
de la société d'état